it's awesome I could have used it on
Saturday yeah the side that you guys
were on where you guys were in the crowd
did anybody jump towards you that way
no the crowd mainly started it was
because we were we had I'm pretty sure
we had Irish right in front of us and
right in front of them was some of
khabib guys and khabees guys were
turning around just literally throwing
the fingers right to the Irish guys the
whole time so then once that happened it
was like I was lucky though I had bad I
had Audrey and Whitney right there
they were Audrey's they were there to
protect yeah they were I was just I was
one of the dumb people just kind of
looking around like there's everybody is
there any immediate danger
no it I mean obviously it seemed way
worse over on your side but I was more
worried when they made us leave because
the further up you got in the bleachers
and once you got out into the concession
area and in the bathrooms that's where
stuff was going down like just people
from the crowd you know guys with Irish
flags all obviously we're getting trash
talked to them and there was a big brawl
right yeah right next to me on the other
side from where they were sitting
oh that's right there was one just to
our right I was looking left believed it
was the guy that jumped in and the
registered on Cubs team when they were
trying to leave when they're getting
them out hmm people in crowd were like
ah they start throwing [ __ ] at them
first that's how the that's where the
first [ __ ] was getting thrown down and
some of the people know that it was them
we we all saw it was like that's the guy
that's the guy right there right now
when he went and tried to do something
you know there's a price to be paid for
all this [ __ ] like all the all the drama
and the trash-talking that makes it so
fun it also you know it has the
potential for blowing up in your face
ultimately like a couple people got
punched but it was in an event where a
bunch of people got punched you know I
mean it's like way more than that it was
awesome yeah but you don't I'm saying
it's like we made it see it seemed like
it was way worse than it really was
because in any other situation it would
be way worse than it really was like if
it was a rock concert and some dudes
just from you know like you know if one
band was the opening band and then there
was another band that was in a brawl
with them and they were they were the
main event and then the fans of one band
threw down with the fans the other band
beat the [ __ ] out of each other that
would for whatever reason be way worse
than when it's at a fight because if
it's out of fight it's just fighters oh
I saw this insane clown this was going
on this insane clown posse guy tried to
dropkick Fred Durst he printer's wasn't
even looking at him running head start
and misses Hey look at he turns her eyes
like what and he just kept going I
haven't seen that dragon off I mean that
is maybe the worst public dropkick in
the history of the world I think they
meant he dropped when he tried to kick
well he tried it sir that was a classic
dropkick classic pro wrestling dropped
it but his problem is he threw it like a
pro wrestler would where you don't
really hit the guy you know I mean just
kind of touched him and if Fred was
playing along it would have been awesome
we need a slow motor Fred would have
went flying and it would have been you
know [ __ ] I think a lot of the lot of
the thing that's going through people's
minds too is when you're at a fight like
that there's a lot of people in the
crowd that can throw down yes not like
you know you go to a well if you go to a
hard a hard rock concert of any kind
Clay Guida is gonna be there somewhere
obviously
but as long as you can avoid clay-like
your opportunity of finding a guy that
can really throw cuffs is gonna be way
smaller than when you're at the UFC and
you look around it's hard not to see
cauliflower here yeah so I mean someone
who's in the crowd that's just a [ __ ]
talker he knows if I just turn around
and talk [ __ ] I could get wrapped up and
be dead quick yeah that's a very high
number of people that could [ __ ] you up
and one of those events it's probably
like 30% 30% of the people in the
audience actually know how to fight
that's high I think that I think it'd be
higher at a UFC yeah at least a basic I
think it's about 30 I'd say about 30% I
feel like if you just like parse the
audience out like how many how many guys
ever been punched
how many guys ever [ __ ] somebody up
how many guys actually trained how many
guys know how to Train and like do it on
a regular basis how many guys are in
shape like if [ __ ] went down
how many guys could actually throw down
for a solid dirty sighs yeah yeah that's
that's that's where you that's where I
would shine I'm gonna ride this out for
two minutes and then these these giraffe
elk legs are getting ready to friggin
start dancing on some people let's be
the spaz out for a little while and then
that